[Applause]
[Applause]
okay 365 here's the latest I am God
knows where I am Nancy don't know man an
air-filled hour we are going to shoot
the portion of the cold open where I'm
stranded by Andy Richter and I have no
way to get to comic-con so what I do is
I find a old World War one plane and I
fly it
which will then take us nicely into a
segment of a very popular movie that's
all I gotta say
maybe this airs after you've already
seen the cold open so you know that it's
Wonder Woman so I should even be coy
anyway here we are it was in 1929
Travel their sort of assessment of its
day that's a pretty straight engine
two-seater plane and I'll be pertaining
to fly it
I don't really fly a plane but I like to
know about that that's all I have for
now watch this
[Applause]
[Applause]
see
well gal gadot see me crap no
[Applause]
[Applause]
garbage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh good you got it
but you were just pants we'll go under
our seventies